let's talk about this first story joe
biden just addressed
gun violence and uh i'm just i'm really
pissed off guys
biden calls for ban on assault weapons
and new red flag laws the president said
the measures were not about taking away
anyone's guns he also acknowledged that
congress might not come to a consensus
even as the nation grieves the victims
of several mass shootings okay let me
just say this i hope you failed joe
biden i hope you failed because you are
a liar
you you are manipulating people and to
anybody who liked what joe biden had to
say i ask you a simple question what is
an assault weapon
what was he talking about banning
bayonets that's if you matt walsh's next
documentary what is that's
nobody knows what it is okay what is a
woman nobody knows in this segment is
brought to you by assault rifle
well that's 10 percent that was dead on
though it was really good
i mean if they do what is an assault
weapon that actually that actually is a
really good idea because they don't have
a definition and this is what really
bothers me is when he lies
the closest approximation is assault
rifle assault rifles haven't been uh
you can't manufactur i could be wrong
about all this but i'm pretty sure you
can't manufacture them after 1986 for
civilian use in order for a civilian to
buy one it's got to be pre-1986 and it
takes you about a year to get because
you've got to get tax stamp fingerprint
you've got to file uh uh it's it's
through the nfa so you got to file atf
forms
i i've i have uh i i can't do it i'll
tell you why i am too busy
so the amount of work required to
actually jump through the hoops to get
an nfa item an nfa regulated item
national firearms act is just
prohibitive for even someone like me
unless i want to take time off work so i
can go down to the sheriff's department
get my fingerprints and all that i'll
tell you what the craziest thing is
first of all red flag laws are insane
and this i got to give a shout out to
maj toure and black guns matter when he
says all gun control is racist that's
right what do you think these police
will do with red flag laws with a red
flag law it doesn't matter if you even
have a gun it gives them powers to
violate your fourth amendment rights
they will come to your house and say
we're searching a warrant on a red flag
and the guy's going back but i don't
have a gun well we don't know that for
sure
don't give the police these powers but
more importantly
what really triggered me i was triggered
well said i was ringing and i was it was
pretty bad swinging my arms get this gun
control off my country it's really bad
when he said he wanted to end the
72-hour release for background checks
for those that don't know
if you want to buy a gun
you have to get a background check i do
let me just write this down write this
down i live in brooklyn new york oh you
can't get this oh forget it the response
time is 72 hours for police so
well you can't get one anyway so now
they want to ban body armor check it out
you go to the store you walk up and you
say i'd like to buy i like to purchase
this this weapon why wh for my my own
personal reasons to defend my home for
sport or
to protect this country from enemies
both foreign to domestic whatever it is
is your fancy right it's your right
you've got to fill out a knicks form
it's it's it's it's not that big a deal
to fill out the form
then they submit it and you have to wait
they're running a background check
the first time i bought uh a gun
they told me you are delayed and you
will have to come back
we'll let you know when you're cleared
72 hours later i got a phone call saying
you are now cleared
i went in and i was able to pick up the
weapon
turns out they never actually did the
background check my understanding is
that
it went long and so my rights as an
american citizen under the second
amendment
i get to take the weapon
if they get rid of that
that restriction on the government
you're going to have federal agents
they're going to say you know we just
don't like this james o'keefe guy huh
we'll do his background check when we
when we get time
and then three months goes by and you're
like where's my background check and
they're like we're working on it
that's what joe biden wants to get rid
of that would give the government the
ability to effectively ban all the guns
at a whim whenever they so decide
and of course they'll give you every
excuse they'll say you know we're just
backlogged and so understaffed sorry
you know what they did with marijuana
back in the day
what they did was you needed a tax stamp
if you wanted to buy it then they
stopped issuing stamps effectively
making it illegal bypassing people's
constitutional rights this is what they
will do joe biden wants to he wants
universal background checks on all sales
including private sales which means you
can't even transfer a weapon to a family
member if you're say you're you're jim
bob and billie jean out in the mountains
of west virginia and you're like i'd
like to transfer this weapon to you
because i'm leaving and we got critters
and bears or whatever can't do it gotta
drive to an ffl and you gotta fill out
the background check form and then
oopsie
the feds have decided there's not gonna
do it
that's how they ban guns so no no joe
biden screw you you're a liar is he more
serious when he's screaming or
whispering do you guys can you guys tell
the difference i don't know because i
agreement notice he'll start with the
yell and then he'll end with the wizard
where are you guys because you're raised
okay he's doing that he always gets real
low at the end oh
he got it from obama
and so does beto o'rourke he does like
owen wilson is uh training him i mean
come on
yeah he's a bad dude
he has to get real low with it wow i'm
not doing it i think i think it's
actually uh the reason he whispers
is because when he loses where he's
going and he can't think it gives him it
gives him an ex a justification for why
he pauses yeah so he'll be like you know
we gotta
ban the guns like it's like i was gonna
say oh i got it i got it
and then he says something low so it's
like the pause was supposed to be drama
as opposed to dramatic instead of just
sad he can't emphatically say what he's
saying because he's reading it he
doesn't really believe it or really
understand it so then he appeals to tone
he'll try and do a begging tone like
this
yeah because he thinks maybe the tone
will get them because obama did that he
used to do that a lot it was really
insidious but obama was a better actor
you'd probably speak to this point like
joe when biden speaks it's just like wow
he's an awful actor and he has no
grounding in principles or morals or any
ethics
yeah but but he has he doesn't he he
can't
muster up the delivery yeah yeah like
obama could obama
deliver as a white guy i can't do an
impression of
a complete idiot yeah so um yes we would
discourage that can't do the obama can't
do eric adams either
oh man
joe biden whenever he gets mad it's it's
so obviously performative
come on man yeah you know it's just like
bro i can tell you're not really
indignant man or jack either one jack
manager check it's like the fakest
you're phoning it in dude yeah he throws
his hands up
remember when he got mad at that uh
that guy who was a union worker who was
like you're trying to ban my guns then
he got really angry and started yelling
at him he like punched the guy he'll let
go up and he can try to like jab him
yeah joe biden's a bad guy
he's a bad guy hangs out with some bad
boys that's right he's a mean fella wow
he's so unremarkable too
somebody asked me recently they were
just like what would you ask joe biden
if you could interview him and as a
journalist i really pondered on that i
was just like man what would i ask joe
biden i really couldn't muster up a good
meaningful question because i feel like
his record is so unremarkable and so
uninteresting that i feel like i would
just be better off trolling him at this
point in his life even though that might
be considered a little bit mean i'd
never heard of him until he ran against
obama and i was like this is the this is
the establishment character they're
using to run against obama more than
hillary i was like who is this well that
was old dude i thought he was a
plagiarist from the 80s and had to
resign from this presidential run
basically
the idea with biden was will america
elect a younger black man
so they were like let's get an older
white dude and put him together so we
can try and maximize our potential and
then it's funny because mccain went with
sarah palin right they were like
let's try a woman and it was just like
yo get the pandering out of there it's
not albany although i think sarah palin
was way better than mccain was so easily
she definitely helped his campaign for
whatever it was but he loses anyway
mccain kept saying my friend he'd keep
calling people my friend all of a sudden
as soon as he started campaigning like
these aren't your friends dude she's
like my friend you know i really like
you you got to blow up a bunch of people
in the middle east and i was just like i
don't want to vote for that guy and then
obama was like i'm gonna
and the wars and i was like i'll vote
for that that's a good obama yeah but
then as soon as he did he's like i'm
gonna blow up these kids
it's like i am uh president and uh i
blow up kids you can't steal you're
stealing that impression from a black
person you're taking somebody's job you
can't do that tim yeah come on well
actually hold on i'm not joking i'm i'm
mixed race and mixed race is the
smallest minority in the country so i'm
actually the most depressed oh i'm sorry
man you're right you can write down make
sure you make sure you take note of that
i love how they're listing the you know
it's like the first openly gay
black press they don't do that for any
of the crappy jobs right they're like
the first
genderqueer ambiguous you know
ambidextrous janitor no one gives a crap
about
any of the mundane jobs at the white
house be great if they could like mop
with two hands at once great yeah really
useful that's why yeah truly
great
at what i do super useful you know and
and to be fair
it's probably because they're already a
bunch of trans abled you know demi
janitors or whatever right but you know
i think it's a fair point to be like we
got to respect the trades and you could
and society just literally doesn't do it
so if they did come out i'd actually
respect it more if they were like our
school hired the first gay janitor i'd
be like no all right but when they're
like this highlight them keep an eye on
them
when they come out and they're like this
hype you know they say like this is the
first official or whatever and then they
ignore the republican ones
it's like was it wasn't like the first
republican member of a black member of
congress like in the 1800s and for the
democrats it was like 1992 or something
like that yeah
i thought when they when tulsi gabbard
was running for president uh in this
last cycle and they were like well we
can't we can't cast her as the role
because we need a woman of color i was
like okay
she is a woman of color
the
the shark is jumped like we just lost it
they they it the shark has jumped yes
shark has jumped everybody remembers
when the shark jumped over the phone
that's right yes
yeah apparently that's when the show has
gone too far it's lost the plot it's
gone like right if you wanted a woman of
color you had a woman of color you
pretended like she wasn't a woman of
color because you want an authoritarian
and that's what you're saying and you
just want to use the color as an option
not enough color yeah well i love it
they're like
you know we need more representation for
marginalized voices and then candace
owens is like i'm going to do a popular
show and they go not you
yeah yeah you're out no you're a white
supremacist or larry elder it's just
like
no they really it's funny because they
throw all these racial slurs at um you
know like
candace owens or larry elder
calling i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
repeat the words they use but they but
they'll call them like the token or
whatever that republicans will rely on
right and then literally all they do is
that they bring about these the these
marginalized voices who just
repeat their own opinions for them
it's funny because you can actually have
like candace owens argue with someone
but then you'll have these like um
diversity candidates for these these
public jobs espousing mainstream
opinions as if they're being puppeted by
these corporations
that's them doing exactly what they're
claiming the right is doing
projection is
it's
you know what i really hate saying it
because it's like the 800th time we'll
have said it but they project everything
what's it yeah it's like why am i why
why am i looking up to like candace
owens and larry elder
to to like
speak up for you know
like for white men really yeah i mean
like that's really what happened though
like i i was like why am i getting uh
why do i feel like candace owens has my
back
more than the president or somebody and
they'll go well they're just a white
supremacist like what
is happening right now
a black person could be a white
supremacist
well it's incredible i think they're
conflating it with roman supremacy i
brought this up a couple times they call
it white supremacy make it a race thing
but like the roman culture enslaved most
of the world that they could get their
hands on they built the roman catholic
church to mentally enslave people and
like it's predominated our society this
roman catholicism this roman now it's
like the british government with their
banks their international bank like it's
all kind of now we're talking residuals
of the romans
seamus is sitting at home and he's going
oh yeah
i love
it defend yourself james is not here to
to push back on the religious stuff i
don't know about all that um but i see
what you're saying right the the roman
empire falls then you get the european
empires the various nations the holy
roman empire it was like germanic but
then you end up with colonization from a
variety of european powers after this
after the you know the empire falls so
ultimately i don't think they have any
idea what they're talking about i think
they're just saying things that use
morsels of truth to manipulate you and
so they can gain power yeah racism
right they know that we all don't like
racism they know that the average
american does not like racism so they
use the fear of you being called a
racist it works well i don't think it's
working so much no no yeah people aren't
having it it happened in 2016 i was
trying to explain hillary his email dump
to wikileaks to my friend and he was
like uh it's just your white privilege
and i didn't know how to defend myself
i can't i don't think so i'm just
leaving it you felt yourself so dirty i
there's a real simple uh thing that i
live by and it's just if you don't know
ask
so if someone's like this is your white
privilege i'll go oh what is it what's
that yeah yeah and then they'll say
something like because you're white x y
and z
and then ask them again be like
you know what do you think about poor
people like what do you think about poor
white people just keep asking them
questions to make them
answer the socratic method essentially
and then eventually when they break
their own logic they're just like i
don't know
and you know it's i don't know what do
you mean by that
and then
you'd lightly argue with them be like i
don't i don't i don't know about that
one he was like it's her time ian it's
her time
and i was like you're just it's your
white privilege yeah i'm like what does
it have to do with her i thought i was
like is that in my mail privilege or
wait uh
i digress but here's what i do
you know it's if times are definitely
changed now where we've bifurcated so
much politically that i don't know if
these methods work but when i would have
people say stuff like to me like about
hillary i'd be like
what do you mean by it's her time and
they'll be like well hillary's been in
government for so long blah blah blah
and i'll be like oh do
you think that makes her a good
president like you think she'll be a
good president
and then just have a mask like ask him
these things and then once they start
getting angry the way like i've
experienced that too i always just be
like i'm sorry man i don't i didn't mean
to make you angry depends what you mean
and then they gotta calm down yes what
do you mean by the word word but the one
thing
word the one thing i always like is like
if you're asking
questions because someone's making these
outrageous statements i don't mean
anything and then they get really really
angry you just say i don't understand
why you're being so mean or i don't
understand why you're yelling at me
yeah rather than continue to try to
drive on what i was talking about about
the emails i should have started asking
about his feelings and stuff that's so
technical if someone's using an emotion
if someone's emotionally enraged they're
not going to think straight their
logical centers in their minds are
shutting down the emotions taking over
and now you want to ask them like
yo are you all right
like are you mad i'm sorry why are you
being mean that's right it's the same
psychological tactic that you want to
use with children you know because like
you have to use child psychology to deal
with children and often times adults
behave like children so you want to use
the same
techniques of a psychologist that deals
with children to deal with adults that
are behaving like children right and i
know that this is true not because i
have children but because i saw a tick
talk about it
and also reverse psychology yes so when
someone says they want to vote for you
know joe biden you go uh well
i already voted for joe biden and you
disagree with me and then they'll go i'm
not voting for joe biden i'm actually
voting for trump's like all right
and that works too no that never works
but that i love that
technically in some areas it literally
did work there's that babylon beam joke
where they said ingenious move trump
comes out in support of impeachment so
that democrats must oppose
because that's what they did trump could
come out and be like pancakes are great
and they'd be like pancakes are terrible
they're racist the racist history of
pancakes
there's 400 genders there's so many yes
we're all polyamorous we're all fluent
they say sure we're fluid we're so
fluent and then they'd come out and be
like we're all straight now yeah oh yeah
perfect i just want to say you're like
four for four or five for five with the
impressions you like i mean i i'm not
keeping track or anything but i think
you're for can you tell what i did in my
room growing up with all my weight shame
i just like well i guess i'll talk to
myself did you do it in a mirror oh yeah
oh no yes oh yeah jim carrey did that a
lot mm-hmm
that was good but i just don't like jim
carrey yeah yeah i like him these days
what kind of millennial are you tim i
thought you were a millennial with the
rest of us you don't really know
yes
he's
he's
he's like a self-righteous arrogant guy
he's spoken
oh no i think it's been broken he did
speak out in the 90s he meant a lot to
us bruce almighty was awesome yes yeah
and then they did evan almighty and i
was like wow
i mean dumb and dumber's my favorite
movie of all it's just good i thought
the ace ventura was definitely a home
run yeah nothing had come out like that
table guy
now how are we talking about jim carrey
well he he talked smack about will smith
when he popped um chris rock at the
oscars and he was like came out publicly
and was like it's yeah he's you know
derided it basically it was nice to see
a celebrity do that an actor yeah yeah
you know you know what i i prefer is
like
i i like people who are willing to be
like wow i didn't know that
that's about it and so like seeing
seeing so many celebrities come out
talking big acting like they know
everything and they don't they're making
everything worse it's frustrating
because the way i describe it is like
imagine you're trying to fix an engine
actually we talked about this with one
of the progressive guests and then
you've got a guy standing next to you
yelling that you've got to like you got
to put the engine fluid in the blinker
fluid and you're like that's that's not
a thing there's no i saw it i i know you
you're you're insane okay we need and
then they all vote we vote we pour the
water in that valve and you're like
you're gonna break the engine and they
do and you're like
i needed that engine too man
along those lines last night we were
talking about the johnny depp amber
heard thing i'm not touching it really
quick because i said some stuff i said
like just a couple of drunk cokeheads
beating each other up and people like
ian
johnny depp wasn't beating her up i
didn't really follow the trial it
probably did come off kind of ignorant
to speak with that kind of authority and
amber hurt is definitely a liar so i
want to get that on record she said that
she donated money to charity when she
had actually actually pledged the the
money yeah and then when they caught her
on the stand lying under oath they're
like you said you pledged it but you
didn't donate it she's like so did you
did you donate i pledged it yeah i
pledged it that's not what i'm asking
i'm asking if you donated it i pledged
it
i pledged it yeah i don't i i pledged it
she was like i use those words
interchangeably and she keeps a
permanent pouty face i don't think she's
just the whole
whole trial
it was i don't want to talk to you it
was happy about people
it was fun he's he's fat he was
fascinating to watch i thought you could
say he was fat yeah
i was gonna breathe that's all i took
from him no so fat he was so fat
i was gonna agree because i was like fat
and he looked a little thick you know
but he would do these like 20-minute
stories to get to this crazy thing she
did like and i i woke up in the morning
and i there's a light due outside i
i saw a small injured crow i knitted a
small cashmere sweater
scissor hands when i realized miss has
heard had taken a crap into my laptop
you're like just get to the crap in the
laptop thing exciting he's got to build
suspension yeah you think he'll be in
like he'll his career will will have a
resurgence i think him and will smith
should be put into some something
yes absolutely and uh it's it's like
maybe it should be space pirates oh yeah
and aliens yeah that's cool
you know he was off playing a live show
in london yeah when the verdict came out
he is like jack sparrow at this point he
is yeah yeah yeah no he's in he's in
brandon territory i don't know if i'm
the only one that remembers how the
trajectory of brando's who brando was
also a very uh kind of a central figure
in johnny depp's life i think in many
ways he wanted to be brando okay and i
think that depp is pretty much at the
brando point his career because brando
had to go on trial for his sons yeah
there was like a i think there's some
sort of murder trial that someone was
involved in and brando had to take the
stand and in this weird way depp is in
the same position that he's in i think
he's in brando territory he's never
going to recover he was also banging
amber heard brando so i think yeah yeah
yeah yeah to his credit i guess yes
all right thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there